BETTER REP BUT HE POINTS OUT
THAT HE WAS IN
THENTO THE
CORNER THERE WITH OLLI MAATTTTHN
21st.
THE RED WINGS, BOXED OUT ON THE
PENALTY KILL AND N BACK ON SEAN.
A THREE-ON-TWO THE
AS THE BEST .
ANOTHER SAVE BY QUICK, OFF OF 3.
GAMES, ANYWAY.
KEN: YES, STREET HOCKEY UNTIL I
HAD SIDE OF
THE NET. OTHER THREE HALL
OF FAMER, JACQUES
IT WENTUMP-IN
JUST LIKE THAT, TYING THE GAME.N
SUNDAY THE LINEUP AS WELL
AND THATOARDS, STAAL.
LEMIEUX HAS IT A HIGH-STICK OR
NOT?
I DON'T KNOW. AND HERE AGAIN. HD
THAT KOPITAR WAS NEARING
LINDSTROM AND, OH, YEAH, RIGHT
AND OUT IN FRONT THIS TIME,
SUTER. THE PENALTY BOX,
MOORE, HE EXPERTS
SAY, OH, HE GOT TOO MUCH MONEY.
REALLY?
KEN: AND KAL
AND MAATTA.CHANGING.
DOUGHTY, BERTUZZI THERE, A L.A.T
FOUR.P FIRST GOAL IN 18
HERE.